how much faster is the brand new M2 Pro
16 inch MacBook Pro compared to the
previous version and how should that
impact your buying decision because
right now the old version is 2100 on
Amazon that's 400 savings and if you get
the one terabyte hard drive that's 500
off compared to the M2 Pro so in this
video we're going to be comparing
everything including a bunch of
different Benchmark and real world tasks
including actually comparing things that
other reviewers didn't mention like
speaker differences which there are at
least we had with the 14 inch and the
webcam improvements as well so let's get
right into it but before I do that I do
want to mention that we're doing a
giveaway of a new M2 Pro MacBook Pro and
new Mac Mini and all you have to do to
enter is subscribe below enable
notifications and comment down below to
enter and you can actually get more
entries by commenting on all of our Mac
videos this month and we're gonna
announce the winner on February 1st so
don't miss out on that video now in this
video we're also going to be doing a
battery life test so they're both
charged up to a hundred percent right
now and I'm gonna go ahead and unplug
them and we should be expecting better
battery life because of the extra
efficiency cores but we'll see now
getting right into it we have both base
models which means they're both twenty
five hundred dollars MSRP but on the new
one we do have some advantages including
the new HDMI 2.1 which supports 4K at
240 hertz including 8K 60 displays while
the old one does not it has a nice
little bonus the new ones do get a color
matched magsafe 3 cable now if you
didn't see our SSD comparison video the
new ones do have a little bit of an
issue where instead of a five SSD Nan
chips on the previous M1 Pro we now get
only two of them which is leading to
slower SSD speeds up to two times slower
for the read speed and then that in turn
led to worse memory swap perform
comments and certain tasks that are very
memory intensive including Lightroom
classic photo editing and we got those
bad results while multitasking with 15
Chrome tabs open because before having
those tabs open the new M2 Pro was 13
faster but then with the Chrome tabs the
old version was actually 17 faster so it
can have an impact in certain tasks but
not as bad in others like in video
editing now one thing that we noticed on
the new 14-inch M2 pro model was that
the speakers actually got a little bit
quieter and less sharp so let's go ahead
and test out the 16 inch models but
before I get into that I've got to give
a shout out to our sponsor Terra box the
best free cloud storage app out there
with one terabyte of free cloud storage
with no cash so you can upload your
files photos and videos to the cloud for
free including automated backup large
file transfer personal Vault and face ID
password and Terra box is also ISO ie C
certified for cloud data security to
keep your data safe you can also try
their premium version with a lower price
that bumps it up to two terabytes
removes ads and adds a multi-speed video
playback so check out Terra box using
the link below
[Applause]
[Music]
and yep it looks like we have the same
thing on the 16 inch models the new one
Cuts those highs down a little bit
compared to the older one which I prefer
the older one for vocals and watching
movies and everything else so it's a
little disappointing but it's not that
big of a difference now one nice little
update that Apple made to the M2 Pro
MacBook Pro is that the webcam actually
looks different even though it's the
same 1080p webcam the new M2 ISP or
image signal processor is actually
improving the quality as you can see
right here and this is on the M1 Pro 16
inch and you can see that it's not as
sharp the white balance a little bit
different it looks like there's more
noise reduction so I do like the changes
with the new M2 pro model and now let's
get into The Benchmark testing with
geekbench 5 and the first thing I want
to point out is the clock speeds which
is now 3.48 on the M2 Pro compared to
3.22 that's about 10 percent higher so
we should expect expect at least that
much of an improvement in the single
core so let me go ahead and start the
test and I do want to mention that this
year we do have double the efficiency
cores four instead of two and they're
actually clocked higher as well and I'll
show you guys when we test out cinebench
we have our scores back and it looks
like we have 10 of an improvement on
single core just as expected it lines up
to the frequency Improvement and 21 on
multi-core which is slightly better than
Apple's quoted 20 so great Improvement
here now the nice thing about that
single core Improvement is that it
should also boost your web browsing
snappiness so let's run speedometer 2.0
which is a web browsing Benchmark and
there you go we have our scores 422 for
the M2 Pro compared to 368 that's almost
a 15 Improvement in web browser
snappiness that's actually really nice
and a lot of people say that might not
make a big difference or a big deal but
there are apps that are web browser
based so all of those will be improved
and actually let's go ahead and run
figma which is a web browser based app
now this figma project right here is
basically what a web designer would do
to create web pages and it's provided to
us by 500 designs which is one of the
best design companies out there so here
I'm basically just going to zoom in to
test how fast it loads up I believe yep
there you go just a couple of seconds
and it's nice and sharp let's do it on
the other machine
and wow it almost did seem like it
loaded faster like I didn't even see it
in low res and now let's go ahead and
Export these 12 layers which is going to
be a standardized Benchmark for us going
into the future so I'm going to click
export and there you go we have our
times it looks like the M1 Pro took a
minute and 49 seconds compared to a
minute and 36 so that makes the new M2
Pro 13 and a half percent faster for
figma web design and now let's get into
the geekbench 5 Metal Graphics Benchmark
and the interesting difference this year
is that the M2 Pro now has 19 GPU cores
compared to 16 on the M1 Pro both
upgraded and non-bined so let's run this
and there you go we have our scores and
it looks like the M2 Pro is around 26
faster so let's go ahead and test some
real world applications like gfx bench
the gaming test now we usually run the
1440p Asic ruins High tier off screen
test but this time we're gonna add in
the 4K test which is new the test is
finished and it looks like we have 28
faster for the 4K test on the M2 Pro and
29 on the 1440p test so it's basically
around the same performance difference
close to 30 like apple quoted and now
just for good measure let's go ahead and
test out 3dmarks Wildlife extreme on
unlimited mode because I think that did
push a little bit more power previously
so let's test it out now while this is
running I went ahead and turned on
acetop provided to us by Timothy Lou and
it looks like the actual clock speed of
the GPU is running eight percent higher
on the M2 Pro compared to the M1 Pro and
another difference I noticed was
actually the peak wattage where the M2
Pro hit 27.14 watts compared to
22.72 on the M1 Pro that's actually a 20
increase in Peak wattage for the GPU
course and now looking at the actual
cores that 20 percent boost in wattage
gave us 26 percent higher FPS so still
pretty good but still not reaching the
30 that Apple quoted and now let's get
into cinebench R23 which is going to put
a 100 load onto the CPU basically a CPU
rendering load so I'm gonna go ahead and
get a baseline reading of the Temps so
right here you can see we have 34 33
degrees Celsius right there hot spot on
the M1 Pro and on the M2 Pro basically
the same thing 3233 so let's go ahead
and start the 10 minute test and I do
have MX power Gadget which is basically
Intel power Gadget brought back to Apple
silicon thank you Ben bajarin on Twitter
and look at that we are using more power
35 Watts on the M2 Pro compared to 28
right now we have higher clock speed
right there you can see the performance
course 3.26 compared to 3.04 the e-core
is the efficiency course 2.42 compared
to 2.06 and attempts are rising faster
as well look at that looking at TG fan
Pro we have 95 degrees celsius compared
to 85. now one difference is the M1 Pro
the fans are off right now whereas the
M2 pro has actually turned them on 1400
RPM right now and 100 degrees Celsius we
just hit on the N2 Pro while the M1
didn't even hit 90 yet now one thing
that nobody has mentioned yet so far on
YouTube is that the M2 Pro allows the
fan speed to ramp higher look at that
5700 RPM on the right side 5300 on the
left compared to 4700 and 4300 on the M1
Pro so a thousand RPM higher now it's
been running for about six and a half
minutes and one thing that I've noticed
is the actual CPU wattage on the M2 Pro
which is actually around 27 percent more
wattage compared to the M1 Pro so it's
going to be interesting to see how big
of an actual Improvement we get in this
test so now that we're past eight
minutes in this test let's take another
reading from the thermal camera we have
43 degrees Celsius on the M1 Pro the
hottest spot right there and then moving
over we have oh look at that 44 45
degrees Celsius and there you go we have
our scores 30
18664 in the M2 Pro compared to
11305 that's basically 21 faster on the
new machine however it did have to use
about twenty seven percent more power to
get that 21 higher score and that could
easily make a difference in the actual
battery life that you experience with
the new M2 Pro so don't forget that
we're going to reveal the differences at
the end so let's go ahead and run a
stress test where we run cinebench R23
at the same time as Wildlife extreme
putting 100 workload on the CPU and GPU
at the same time oh we just hit 108
degrees you can see that right now on
the M2 Pro wow and the clock speeds are
actually getting cut down look at that
instead of 3.26 we're now at 3.03
basically the same as the M1 Pro machine
the fans are now kicking up I can
actually hear them over 3 500 on the M2
pro at about 30 400 on the M1 Pro the
clock speed kicked back up on the
performance cores on the M2 Pro but you
can see that the GPU clock speed is now
down a little bit compared to what it
was before 1.38 1.39 so the test is
finished and this time we have 19 faster
for the M2 Pro and the nice thing is
that we didn't hit the peak 5700 RPM
that it can go up to now and I think
that's actually meant for the M2 Max
chip which can go up to 38 cores on the
GPU and that machine might actually
throttle based on what we just saw so
definitely subscribe so you don't miss
out on that video and now that we have
thermals and cinebench out of the way
let's move on to some real world
workflows including some X code
programming testing The xcode Benchmark
for maxim aramenco I got the terminal
script ready right here and by the way
if you want to see what's inside of this
actual test just look up xcode Benchmark
online there you go it's starting up and
we can already see these CPUs ramping up
right here you got 99 CPU usage so it's
going full blast and there you go we
have our scores and it looks like the
new M2 Pro finished in 70 seconds which
is insanely fast especially for a base
machine compared to 90 seconds on the
old M1 Pro so there's definitely a great
difference here for programmers and now
let's get to testing music production
with the logic pro Benchmark which you
can actually download and test yourself
on this website and it has specific
information and steps that you should
take to run the test correctly so
basically within logic you go into these
settings you go to Advanced and turn on
the complete features then go back to
audio set it to 1024 buffer size and
choose the maximum amount of processing
threads which we have 12 here because of
the extra efficiency cores then you hit
apply
so basically the point of this test is
to test out the system's stability and
how much CPU usage it has because if it
overloads the CPU it is going to crash
when you're doing your music production
so so far with 128 tracks on each it is
doing just fine and it has to get
through the entire thing without
overloading and stopping to pass the
test all right it just passed on both no
issues at all let's add some more tracks
and now let's test it out with 150
tracks and now it should be kicking up
that CPU a lot more as you can see we're
sitting at 72 percent right now all
right it's almost done and it looks like
87 degrees Celsius still not even bad on
this M2 Pro and now let's go for 180 oh
they both overloaded almost right away
so 180 is too much I've just disabled 10
of them 170. let's try that out oh the
M1 Pro just overloaded and the M2 Pro is
still going fans are kicking up
oh it did overload though the M2 Pro
lasts a little bit longer but overloaded
let's take some more off
165 on each the fans actually kicked up
on the M2 Pro still off on the M1 Pro 97
degrees towards the end of this and it
looks like they both made it with 165.
and look at that 167 and no problem on
both 168. oh there you go M1 Pro just
failed can the M2 make it and it just
finished at 103 degrees Celsius got
super hot but basically both of them
failed at 170 tracks however the M2 Pro
did 169 just barely while the M1 Pro did
168 so there's basically no difference
and the reason for that is because this
mg Pro is overclocked it's using 28 more
wattage to get 21 more performance in
cinnamon so it's using more watts and it
basically makes it kind of unstable so
it's around the same performance in this
test and now let's get into photo
editing with Lightroom classic as you
can see I have 50 raw 42 megapixel
images open right here and I can kind of
cycle through them to show them to you
guys what I'm gonna do is do an export
test because basically in terms of
snappiness and editing they're both
basically the same I got the same export
settings on both of them for 50 images
let's hit X Sport and start the timer
now this is a memory intensive program
or test to run with photo editing
because there's a lot of files being
written a lot of data going back and
forth and I can actually show you in the
activity monitor how there is a lot of
memory swap being used we can see right
here that the M2 Pro is using 5.5 gigs
of swap compared to 2.7 on the M1 Pro
and that is going to be impacted by the
whole SSD situation if you have the base
SSD that's a little bit slower and there
you go the test is finished we have our
scores and it looks like the M2 Pro
MacBook Pro finished in a minute and one
second compared to a minute and 11
seconds on the M1 Pro so that's about 10
seconds faster and there should be a
bigger difference but because we have
that swap with the slower ssds it's not
as fast now if we actually had some
Chrome tabs open like in the previous
video we had 15 of them it actually gets
slowed down like crazy in the M2 Pro
ends up being slower than the M1 Pro so
keep that in mind and if you want to
avoid that if you're a photo editor just
get the one terabyte SSD at least and
now here we have the Affinity photo 2
Benchmark which is going to test the CPU
performance and the GPU performance for
photo editing work that's actually very
well optimized and as far as the GPU we
have 32 faster in terms of the graphics
for photo editing and now let's get into
blender 3D rendering which is going to
be testing out the GPU performance
difference between these two this is
doing Cycles with the gpus let's click
render image all right guys this is
crazy the MC Pro hasn't been finished
for a little bit and the M1 Pro is still
going I can't believe it 100 GPU usage
so it's using it just fine it's still
going with this test holy moly guys it
is done I can't believe the result this
time around the M2 Pro finished in 50
seconds you the s50 compared to a minute
and
58.6 seconds on the M1 Pro that is over
twice as fast for 3D rendering this
ain't no 30 gain over twice as fast for
blender 3D rendering that is absolutely
insane such a huge Improvement and one
interesting thing I'm noticing is that
on the M2 Pro it says the peak memory
usage is 2700 on the M2 Pro and only
1424 on the M1 Pro what if that's
Apple's built-in tile based memory that
they added to the end to approach it
because if you look at the die images
there is a lot of extra transistors in
the M2 Pro GPU not including the cores
themselves compared to the previous M1
Pro so this is a killer killer 3D
rendering upgrade and now let's get into
video editing with Final Cut Pro the
first test we're going to do is our
standard h.26 64 4K export so this is a
five minute project and since hevc is so
popular right now we're just gonna do
the hebc as the final format and there
you go they both finished two minutes
and 52 seconds no difference whatsoever
for h.264 to hebc which is the most
common formats that people use for video
editing and since it didn't matter for
those codecs those formats let's do
prores raw which is high intensity so
let's go ahead and test this out and it
should also have prores encoders so
we'll see if it makes any difference at
all and there you go we have our scores
it took exactly a minute for the M2 Pro
and it took a minute and five seconds
for the M1 Pro practically no real world
difference here even with the five
minute project and now to finish off
with a bang we have Canon R5 8K raw
which is
extremely insane it's a very heavy codec
that should not be supported by the
decoders at least we're going to encode
into hebc and see the difference let's
get started right off the bat both of
the gpus fully maxed out as you can see
right there and the CPU is getting hit
at the same time so this is a very good
mixed use case test and look at that
we're already at over a hundred degrees
Celsius 103 right there 105. wow it is
heating up while this one's still at 89
wow look 106. there you go I'm hearing
the fan kick up on the M2 Pro over 3000
RPM compared to 1500 basically idle on
the M1 Pro and just because I'm curious
I'm turning on MX power Gadget to
monitor exactly what's going on here
right here it looks like we're using
about 49 watts of power compared to 42
on the M1 Pro that's 16 more in terms of
the actual wattage the GPU frequency is
stuck at 1.4 gigahertz compared to 1.3
which is good it's still full blast
without any throttling so far now keep
in mind we did hit 106 degrees maximum
and now it's cooled down to about 100
101. this is actually the test we ran on
the M2 MacBook Air that got it to Thermo
throttle like crazy when it hit 108
degrees Celsius so if you're gonna have
the M2 Max chip then you might actually
see some throttling because it has
double the GPU cores it's going to use a
lot more wattage it might actually
throttle and especially on the 14 inch
MacBook Pro with the M2 Max 38 core
definitely subscribe so you don't miss
out on that video and finally the test
is finished it looks like the M2 Pro
finish in 8 minutes and 17 seconds
compared to 10 minutes and 7 seconds so
a minute and 50 seconds longer finally
we found a test where the M2 Pro got a
huge Advantage but this is Extreme this
is an extreme test most likely you'll be
going for the M2 max if you're doing
crazy stuff like this but it's nice to
see that we did get an improvement so
now after hours of testing let's finally
take a look at the difference in battery
life on the M1 Pro we are left with 11
right now and 12 for the M2 Pro machine
so basically no difference and with that
said I finally have my conclusion
between these two machines if you
already have an M1 Pro or M1 Max MacBook
Pro from 2021 do not upgrade it is not
worth it yes you get 15 to 20 gains and
certain things maybe even up to 30 but I
don't think it's that big of a deal at
least not enough to actually upgrade if
you already have one of these now there
is one task where I think it could
actually be worth it if you already have
an M1 Pro and that is blender 3D
rendering over twice as fast that is
killer and it can help you if you do a
lot of 3D rendering but for everything
else it's not that big of a difference
especially since we have the same
designs the same ports the same displays
same everything between these two
generations sure HDMI 2.1 that could be
a big deal if you already have a really
nice display that can support it but is
it really worth upgrading I mean the
speakers are kind of cut down in terms
of the highs yes the web cam is a little
bit better with the processing but
spending that much money again on an M2
Pro I don't think it's worth it for
almost everybody now if you skipped
these M1 Pro and Max machines now this
is a great time to upgrade if you need a
lot of performance you're going to get
those extra gains and the better specs
like Bluetooth 5.3 Wi-Fi 6E all of that
could be very enticing for you and that
could be a good time to buy but here's
the Dilemma if you don't have either of
these machines yet should you actually
just go for an M1 Pro machine right now
because you can find them discounted
like crazy hundreds of dollars off
twenty one hundred dollars for this 16
inch base instead of 2500 or if you get
the one terabyte SSD you're saving 500
compared to MSRP so some people might
just want to do that if they don't care
about those extra updates to the Wi-Fi
bluetooth specs HDMI all of that they
might actually be a good idea for you so
let me know what you think about this
comparison down in the comment section
below and if you want to check out the
deals on the M1 Pro machines use the
YouTube tagging feature definitely click
subscribe because we're making a lot of
videos with our 12 new 2023 Max so we
have a lot of testing to do thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]